security trusted CST which monitors this
and works closely with the Metropolitan
Police and other police forces has
charted at the very significant rise in
anti-semitic attacks in recent weeks and
that's physical attacks attacking a
rabbi attack on a Jewish woman protests
in london someone as well as verbal and
other such attacks and I think the ones
and powerful things about Mellie Phyllis
is peace is she says you know it's I
mean you can sort of expect politicians
at Miliband David Cameron to condemn
that of course you would expect that but
what she very powerfully puts across in
the pieces that you can't actually deal
with that if politicians continue to
give succor to the lies that allow that
kind of behavior to come back and that's
a really striking thing about speech and
she says unless unless David Cameron so
that says you know we will not allow the
Foreign Office you know we will will
will make sure the Foreign Office
narrative of the Middle East doesn't
continue in this way because it's by
continuing along that narrative that you
see young you know basically thuggish
people behaving outrageously on British
streets yeah and using it as an excuse
to sort of vent all there yeah anger and
then what do you think do you think I
mean at least we can agree that if there
are you know attacks and abuse in in
England that's a very
thing yeah totally and our organization
works very very hard to try and exclude
anyone like that where they try and
enter into our demonstrations fights
against it within the wider movement
yeah um so as someone who's Jewish
myself and actually is someone who has
suffered verbal abuse unya to about on
Twitter this week as a Jewish person in
relation to limitless it's something
we're very much aware of yea though I
think there is a very much a danger in
in both what what my only drives we're
home she extends that to the
formulations that the Foreign Office is
supposedly using in a problematic ways
to accept that there is a military
occupation to accept that there are
illegal settlements yeah those are
things which are very well established
them being both British and US policy
for the 47 years of the occupation and I
think there's a very big danger when you
don't say right we're going to try and
split off this tiny anti-semitic
minority from majority of people who are
writing the majority of what sort of
Muslims in this country people in
general I think it's people in general
if you look at there's a yougov poll out
today which says the sixty-two percent
of people think that Israel is
committing war crimes and that's
including fifty-seven percent of
conservative voters so it this is not
something restricted to the Muslim
community and I think that things we're
both lonely is arguing that and also
actually what Douglas is written that
demonstrations there is no explanation
why people were there of ninety semitism
yeah you can either say that everyone is
a racist and therefore the correct
responses to to ban any kind of simply
with Palestinians or you can say let's
split off the tiny time proportion work
with majority to express the
humanitarian concerns political concerns
I know the classic a response to baggage
the political response and exclude the
violent extremist dignity of course
we'll issue that the first of all of
course it is not a pretty british thing
alone in fact the backlash against
choosing Britain has been really very
modest compared to that across the
continent take the demonstrations in
Paris firebombing of Jewish sent regales
couple of days ago Jews are locked into
a synagogue by a moss
by a mob of people in Germany I mean
gently the front cover of built magazine
last week had to have me a prominent
German the president that the Chancellor
saying there's no place for
anti-semitism generally because Jones
woke up and discovered to their
amazement than mr min Germany calling
for the eradication of Jews that there
was a chant going out on the streets of
Berlin up right at so-called
pro-palestinian protests calling for the
death of all do sir so actually what's
happened in Britain is relatively mild
compared to what's happening other
places but just to respond to this thing
about alleged war crimes and thing I
don't believe that Israel has committed
war crimes I think it's very clear that
it hasn't is that I've tried as a former
colonel for the British Army Richard
Kemp has said the most moral army in
history in precisely trying to avoid
civilian casualty and doing everything
can't avoid that but it's not surprising
is it that you might get young Muslims
and others who might feel that Jews are
responsible for this all that bickering
Israel is committing war crimes and so
on if they read in their papers if they
see certain news bulletins if they see
the distortion of the debate if they see
very willful throwing around of
accusations of for instance war crimes
in a situation it's not surprising given
that some people will feel whipped up
into thinking the way we will respond to
this is to raise awareness by violence
by intimidation by thuggery and other
means and i think that's about changing
what they do with that what actions they
take not the thinking that there are war
crimes as well the majority the rich
public think that there are yes but the
majority british public then are reading
misinformed information and are
observing miss informed media truth has
to matter in the conflict and a side or
a group of people pushing a narrative
that war crimes have been committed is
the sort of thing that is going to feed
into a wider narrative of resentment if
if after all if people like i wrote
herself david john snow on channel 4
news said we you know her concern about
Gaza have been abandoned by our United
Nations abandoned
British government it is only us left
and so on and is this he did after
presenting the Israelis as if they were
just willfully trying to blow up and
kill babies and target babies if you do
that kind of thing you are whipping up
mobs into action you are presenting a
distorted and lying version of the facts
and after engage citizens to actually
engage in democratic process which is
the sort of outlet that we provide but I
agreed that the media frame is very
important so that's when things Israel
refers to itself and that is picked up
in the media as the Jewish state
frequently about that is the standard
naming formulation when you have things
the station ports of the Jewish state
well there are consequences amongst the
ill-informed which when they say this is
being done in the name of Jews and that
is how is represents itself so in in the
lebanon war epidemic prime minister at
the time said i believe this is a war
being fought by all the jews and i think
that is very very dangerous that that's
the kind of formulation well it doesn't
tell you what it's saying is that surely
it is dangerous if as you said have said
if let's say that Israel should present
itself to Jewish state but has been
until now I mean I can't understand
logically but let's pretend that the
fact that Israel disguise itself as a
Jewish state has been part of the
problem would you not at least then add
to that that if people make accusations
of the Israelis being as you have just
done war criminals committing war crimes
and so on then you at the very least are
perpetrating at least the half of that
problem I mean I don't think that the
jura state shouldn't describe itself to
Joseph I think it should describe itself
as a jurist eight but let's say that it
shouldn't and that you and others then
add on top that the problems are the
accusations of war crimes do you not at
least recognize that that is going to be
significantly fueling attacks on Jews
hatred of Jews around the world if one
accepts that is at least a theoretical
possibility for Israel to commit war
crimes as it is for any state yeah then
clearly the problem is not pointing out
whether it is or not and that's a
question of fact
what are its actions and intentions but
the question is then really of unlinking
that from any totally misplaced
retribution against British tube so now
Hamas is clearly the problem for the
Palestinian people it is the thing that
ensures that a Palestinian state cannot
it for the time being exists because the
Israelis cannot do business with a group
that says from their charter onwards
they want to annihilate all do now
that's a bad so why buy a sim fatter
bugs road destroy you would agree that
is the case of Hamas so if it is a
problem of Hamas for Palestinians first
that they cannot have a state as long as
this group is in charge of the guards
and soul and entered as a unity deal
with Fatah why are there not protests
against Qatar in this city why are there
not protest to get outside the embassies
of the of the countries that are funding
and fueling and in fact arming hammers
why is that not happy why has your group
why has not even a dozen protesters
appeared outside any of these embassies
there'll be a protest against the
Egyptian embassy today there were a
jewel partner with Israel in imposing
the siege against the Gaza Strip so I
think how large you expect your room and
key Egypt demonstration to be as big as
that against Israel outside the Israeli
embassy or small about it well the
rejection governments are not currently
bombing gas yeah you see one of the
things about this which is just an
overriding concern I think of people who
are friendly towards the State of Israel
is that in situations like this everyone
becomes a counterterrorism expert
everyone becomes a border ex but
everyone becomes negotiations and peace
expert in actual fact very few people
know what they're talking about the
reality is I would argue that if you rly
if you lessen the blockade that happens
around Gaza in terms of what is allowed
coming what is not Hamas would use the
opportunity to bring in more weaponry
fact is that Israel is doing what it
regards as being in certain interest
this isn't a this isn't something only
right-wing governments do in Israel
left-wing governments do as well there
is a very significant problem for Israel
and I don't doubt this I think Melanie
Phillips and her piece doesn't doubt
this which is since the foundation of
the state and the attempt by all of its
neighbors to annihilated its neighbors
continue to try to annihilate it on a
regular basis until they decided that
they
we couldn't win by military means so
what they've decided to do is to attempt
to win the PR war is attempt to persuade
the world that Israel is uniquely
disgusting state uniquely commits war
crimes uniquely oppresses people and if
they succeed in perpetuating that
narrative they can end Israel not by
military means but by political means
universally now that is exactly what is
underway that is why you hear people
coming out of the world what claiming
that is welcome basically you know I
support yourselves right to exist and
I'd like to see it live in peace but I
don't think it should do the following
or shouldn't do this it shouldn't do
that there's always a next thing it
shouldn't do but it basically what they
are taking part in is a step-by-step
process of stopping Israel being allowed
to defend itself